how's it going everybody so news on the
Avengers 4 trailer it might be dropping
sooner than we think recently within the
last week we've gotten many Avengers for
leaks and the trailer description was
actually one of them now unfortunately
there was no real way to determine if
this was legitimate or not but with all
these leaks happening and the official
trailer coming out hopefully not too far
from now we're gonna know pretty soon
especially with this new rumor I'm still
giving out copies of infinity war and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray and some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter the giveaway is be a
subscriber like the video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero
so as rumor has it right now Avengers 4
footage is going through digital media
remastering and this could be a sign
that the trailer could be with us within
just a few weeks now Avengers 4 was
actually shot entirely with IMAX cameras
so some people may think that it doesn't
have to be digitally remastered however
Avengers infinity war it was actually
the first movie ever to be shot entirely
with IMAX cameras and it still went
through digital media remastering as you
can see here at the bottom of this
picture it says the IMAX release of
Avengers infinity war it will be
digitally remastered into the image and
sound quality the IMAX experience with
proprietary IMAX DMR digital remastering
technology the crystal-clear images
coupled with IMAX is customized theater
geometry and powerful digital audio
create a unique environment that will
make audiences feel as if they are in
the movie that is taken directly from
IMAX comm so if the rumor that the movie
is going through digital remastering is
true we'll probably get the trailer
within a few weeks and before you go and
dismiss this rumor this actually came
from the same person who was right about
the trailer for so low a Star Wars story
and the trailer for the last Jedi so
there is credibility here and with all
these other leaks with Avengers 4
happening it does seem like we're
getting closer and closer to finally
getting the trailer and the title I know
some people are saying that it's going
to drop in December just like Avengers
and
war did but it would make sense for them
to do it in November spider-man into the
spider verse comes out in December and
they'll most likely throw a spider-man
far from home trailer with it but
they're not gonna do that before they
give us an Avengers 4 trailer so again
there's a lot that adds up and points
towards the trailer being released
sometime in November but let me know
your thoughts let me know what you all
think about the possibility of us
getting an Avengers 4 trailer in just a
few weeks and let me know what you're
most looking forward to when Avengers 4
comes out don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]